geez the Heat's gonna kill me Chef's
sake the heat of the kitchen either
makes you or breaks you
this week I meet a chef who it nearly
killed
it was been rushed to hospital I hope
the hell is okay
[Music]
nantwich a wealthy Cheshire town in the
heart of a thriving farming Community
just off the High Street is Oscars named
after Irish writer Oscar Wilde it's been
hard work if I put a lot of money into
it and
I wanted to work out now I'm running out
of excuses
[Music]
12 months ago with the support of a
family Maura put 65 000 pounds her life
savings into opening her dream
restaurant I like I like meeting people
I love meeting people and this is what I
enjoy
one big happy family running a quaint
Irish restaurant perfect
trouble is more is now losing two grand
a week and this place was meant to be
her Pension Plan it's just a nightmare
it really it is a nightmare it's it's a
panic and specially when I'm on my own
you know I have nobody to go home and
share God you know what do you think
more can't afford a head chef
so her son Lennon's heading up the
kitchen for free I'm the one that's
closest to me long so obviously I
wouldn't see her in the lodge and that's
it I've just stayed
but even with Lennon's charitable
contribution it seems Oscars is on its
last legs
are you well I'm very well it's Laura
Laura good
this is uh cozy nice and who's that on
the wall down there who do you think it
is it looks like a fat version of
Jonathan Ross Lenny how are you doing
pleased to meet you and you what's under
here they're the ribs which um
cooking Coca-Cola
cooked in Coca-Cola yeah [__] me that's
a new one honestly God they are they're
cooked in Cocoa Coca-Cola okay Lennon
used to be a pub chef and it looks like
he's picked up some bad habits
and what style of food is it I call a
bit of everything
fish steaks a bit of pasta a bit of
vegetarian try to cover a bit of
everything oh dear I can't wait to find
out what Moore's eclectic menu has to
offer okay thank you King Pawn wrap
green lit mussels soup du jour a little
bit of everything
a good restaurant does one sort of food
brilliantly
a bad one does 50 badly Oscar wild
buffalo buffalo in Cheshire even I'd
find more as menu a challenge
God knows how a son Lennon copes
oh the Boston use this what you have to
pick the thing and where's that
oh thank you my pie and a starter takes
20 minutes to arrive a nice psychedelic
pink crab stick
it stinks as well
then like everyone else I start waiting
and waiting for my main course
what are they doing in there lots of
Cutlery on the table but no [__] food
has anyone told them there are 38
customers in the restaurant
oh tables three and seven have been
cleared for about 20 minutes
with food and service this bad
first-time customers will never come
back
so long for the food now they want a
bottle of complimentary Wayne what can
you do you have to keep the customer
happy
more has been forced to flush what
little profits you could be making
straight down the toilet
at last an hour and a half after
ordering it my carbonara finally arrives
tastes like there's vinegar there
you don't put [__] vinegar in a
carbonara
the egg in there there's no parmesan in
them it's bland it's garlicky chickens
rubbery apart from being crap I'm really
[__] I actually feel really embarrassed
because the girl's behind me haven't
even eaten yet we've been in here since
eight o'clock and it's now 10
wow
[Music]
I'm amazed I've held out this long
what's going on in there and learning is
really [__] embarrassing me out there
let me let me give you a hand so um
who's Community who's communicating
who's doing what no anyone in what's
that Moon down there
obviously the smolding 35 degree heat in
this kitchen has started to scramble
their brains who put it under the grill
guys
do you look after it Liz
this is like a [__] Lauren Harvey
Show
this is another fine mess I've got
myself into
[Applause]
search
it's a fast
[Music]
with mother and son playing the blame
game
where is it
there's nowhere to go in the [__] off
this is the problem we have most of the
time [__] waitresses
no one is taking control
number two is now looking for some
discount I'd say get [__] well you
don't you can't do that
why it's like nearly two yeah
this kitchen's a pressure cooker waiting
to explode
anyway let's not argue let's just try
and get some food out
just let it [__] off
[__] [__] itself
a head chef who can't stand the Heat
what happened to the quaint family run
restaurant
[__] mate it's not normal you know this
is not [__] normal huh doing your mum
a favor is one thing
helping to run her business into the
ground is another you can't be happy
with this it does hurt to see it because
I know that every penny in mom's got is
in her house is in this everything's in
this
[__]
I apologize
more is giving away over a hundred
pounds worth of free drink and food
should have been better off closing for
the night and saving the Russians
reputation
I actually sat down with a little bit of
excitement you know that I think in
Christ this is quaint this is beautiful
then when the food arrives trust me I
don't think quite unless we need to hear
any more bad comments on the food
tonight because I've had a [__] belly
fall we're in the [__]
[Music]
it's my second day at Oscars last night
mother and son team Maura and Lennon ran
possibly the worst service I've ever
seen the first thing that struck me when
I came to the kitchen last night
was the disrespect between mother and
son
that was a big shot for me yes with it
being a family business you know this is
like a livelihood
and I walked out and I I do know
that you know that wasn't right what the
[__] happened last night
um you give it to me truthfully
truthfully
um and seriously and seriously I am
I was nervous about the whole thing and
I did
and I'll openly admit to have a few
drinks yesterday looking up to it and
basically through that I did lose my
concentration at what I was doing
everything just went pear-shaped if I
I'm gonna get involved and start working
[__] hard to help get this thing back
on track
you've really got to promise me that
you're going to concentrate not
disappear and forget anything about a
[__] drink 100
and ten percent I promise you that
I'm really worried about linen turning
to alcohol every time there's pressure
in the kitchen
so many chefs go down that line and if
it's not alcohol it's drugs and that's
the last thing you need when you're
under pressure it's a [__] recipe for
disaster
like he's dad before him Lennon's always
wanted to be a chef but so far I've seen
nothing revolutionary when he's cooking
it's time to find out just what lights
is fire I don't [__] for myself
you don't [__] eat your own food are
you keen on anything
Corey I just like vindaloo Curry for
some reason vindaloo yeah I know I'm red
and I said I'm sick I'll sit with a
bottle of wine with that and I'm happy
enough so you're eating the loose you
smoke 40 cigarettes a day a bottle of
wine sugar sandwiches
sugar what sugar sandwiches
the bread and dip it into the Sugar Bowl
gorgeous
trust me you must have a pan like a
cow's bat side having fried diarrhea
sugar sandwiches and ribs braised in
Coca-Cola
Lennon's taste buds have clearly lost
their Irish Roots lamb I need to inspire
them with some good old-fashioned
ingredients
can be done into three 400 quids worth
of turnover how can you turn that into
something delicious yeah and sell it on
the [__] menu thank you something for
chicken as well you know let's see what
his vivid imagination can muster not out
of a cookbook
they're off the top of my head
it's okay
ready
yep right the chicken marinated in Honey
and whole green mustard so I've done
about a wilted spinach
good I like that yeah yeah I do like
that you had a drink last night last
night yes I didn't do anything last
night it tastes like [__] yeah it tastes
like [__] next dice lamb cooked and
small too and basil sauce and just
topped with Parmesan cheese what a bit
of chili just give a little bit of a
bite
this is why I think you destroyed the
majority of the stuff you do because you
put all these little bits of [__] at the
end that just blows it
I I don't think that's too bad almost
reminds me of a stew like a like an
Irish stew and if I came to Oscars I'd
love to see a real nice Irish shoe if I
knew the chef was Irish bang you'd
expect I'd be over the [__] Moon that
one's workable
but not bad
okay thank you but you can definitely do
better yeah and there's no time like the
present
Irish family
I think we can do it quite sort of
rustic no okay Irish restaurant Irish
stew here we come Shame Shame Shame so
we dry them out a little bit create a
little bit of fur around the outside
almost like a little bit like a fur
jacket an island
welcome back you go back on until you
just start to fluff out why the [__] are
you telling me this yeah in your own
restaurant
when you produce the [__] you produce
and now you've just opened up and hit
the nail on the head you've fallen out
of love with food haven't you and a lot
of people have said that yes I don't
know why no reason why you've got to get
it back
so what does mum think
I'm ashamed to say I'm Irish and I
couldn't make Irish Jewelers this is
lovely yeah your eyes for [__] sake
you should be you know renowned in this
town for your Irish stew
walking around like proud [__] I mean
yeah and it's simple it's amazing it's
cheap
yeah okay mother and son are starting to
see eye to eye now it's time to get
mature trainee Chef Les up to speed I
did not want to be a chef early on in
Life or no I never really never really
occurred to me I mean when I left school
it was just
take what job I could get at the time
really money-wise yeah Les has had 21
jobs in 21 years started cooking at 18.
everything from gas man to bingo caller
give me a call the eyes down here we go
so it's uh on the blue four and two blue
42. Two Fat Ladies 88 all the sevens a
pair of crutches 77. if he can cook as
well as he can call then job 22 could be
the winning number
section two Clickety knock 62. read all
the ones like it's 11.
oh they whistle of course yeah thank you
the chefs may be on side but if Oscars
is empty midweek it doesn't matter how
much we improve the food how much do you
need to take a week to break even
to break even about three and a half
thousand and what are you taking on
average at a minute is two two thousand
relationships are frail and businesses
down the pan but how long can you
continue surviving like this oh
foreign
I just can't carry on like this much
longer it's a nightmare I'm I am getting
worried
my dream is just going down the street
where's the butcher Craig Moore's never
run a Russian before an upstairs
establishments are the hardest to fill
so she's got to get her business head on
your windows yeah they're [__]
amazing I've never seen such phenomenal
space in all my life you know that she's
been ignoring a tailor-made marketing
Solution that's right on her doorstep
walking down here Craig is totally
oblivious there's any restaurant hey
Chinese next door fine but bloody hell I
want to know what's going up in there
does any customers ever tell you that no
they don't know where the restaurant is
yeah didn't know you were here I think
you know what's coming what I want to do
is pull those beautiful big blinds down
and just stick Oscars
classic Irish cooking upstairs telephone
number and what I'd like to do is try to
come to Summer raised where you can
bring your family for a little bite to
eat
more will host the table and we can have
that bitter sort of working relationship
together that'd be brilliant for us yeah
I'm just trying to think of ways that we
can have as a bit of a marketing tool
without having to spend shed loads of
money thank you butcher's handshake
solid as a rock building a reciprocal
relationship with the butcher is key to
Oscar's success currently we're using
upstairs your fillet steak revive ribeye
the chicken chicken the chicken and the
ribs and the ribs and is it um local
lamb local lamp or local produced yes
thank you by making full use of his
local suppliers Lenin and his customers
will be getting a better deal
food on the day new menu
it's going to be a new menu on there so
and with Craig's name all over it yes
I'll say we'll put your name on our menu
this is where we get our meat so we need
good discount
I don't know what you're laughing I
don't serious
he's getting the hang of this
so I'm going to push him even further I
want Lennon to buy lunch for 15 surprise
guests 30 quid on 30 questions I'm 30
quid so what's two pound ahead five
please cheers if he can stick to a
budget he'll make more profit for the
restaurant
holds in the potatoes apparently I'll
give you 60 Pence one because then
you're not taking the money off though
definitely got the gift of the gap are
you good at this yeah
but can he transfer some of that energy
into the kitchen are you lazy
yes I'd say that yes you are
why have you turned lazy
um I don't I I can't I don't know
probably because no one's driving you
behind and telling you what to do yes
uh-huh yeah maybe you've just hit the
nail on Earth your mum is a weak lady I
know that so she's not gonna be there
[__] gaining you and [__] telling
you off no I get annoyed with her and
that's when the argument starts they say
never work with children or family
today they're all here but I'm keeping
Lenin in the dark my little surprise let
me just say this is one table
right now Lenny you can't afford to [__]
up right yeah it won't be [__] up it
better not be because his family are his
harshest critics especially his younger
brother Gilly I've been a few times
where I've gone I haven't been overly
impressed I'm not sure that repeating
the same dish constantly he can do at
the same sort of level I think that that
is his biggest issue this is a chance
for you to show me that you can cook and
control something from scratch and
create something which is not on the
menu something completely different and
something a little bit inspirational
right excite me
light my [__] fire
everything is fresh cooked fresh
all bought locally it's
oh [__] you write me a [__] storyline
or something because I had no idea what
what you want me to say what I'm trying
to get out Lenny is some [__] passion
some [__] care and attention and love
for food Blow Me Away deep fried local
mushrooms stuffed with mature cheddar
cheese good slow roasted pork finished
with sage sounds nice it is it is fresh
local strawberries served on a bed of
cream there you go what was different on
there
it's all that [__] you're telling me
was so hard that's sounding fantastic
that's not too bad but the pennies just
drop with me because that's what you are
lacking in confidence
a chef without confidence is like a car
without wheels and Lenin's got to get in
that driving seat
if he can woo the family with a simple
roast dinner that's half the battle see
this rock salt here we'll rub it in
there like that it takes out the water
now the fat what happens to the fat
goes nice and crisp it up there you go
the other half of the battle is making
full use of his assistant Les you're an
important member of this team we need
you here and you're going to feel a lot
safer when this guy's connecting
connected do you know that you
definitely need help
maybe this will be a turning point for
Lennon and with his confidence boosted
we can concentrate on his cooking good
good
hey hello three and a half minutes for
15 main courses
yeah [__] well done do me a favor and
[__] off out there go on
it's time for Lennon
to meet his surprise guests
so how's he fared
this is gorgeous it is absolutely
gorgeous
what's the meat that's in with the
Cabbage bacon onion black pepper but he
does have a connection with food
unfortunately he just lacks the
confidence that's the real sad thing
about this guy cooking for your family
is [__] difficult because they have
been criticizing for a long time I just
wish he can actually do the same now for
his customers because if he gets that
right we've got a chance to get this
place back on the [__] map
it's Saturday night and Oscars is fully
booked and I want you to make it here a
favor Lenny's working with Maura's
expansive menu
but to give him a Fighting Chance there
has to be a system so that's nice and
clear table seven four customers
communication between front of house and
kitchen must be seamless times on there
so we can really concentrate on getting
the food out and there's no one's
arguing then because you're saying it's
25 minutes and he's saying no bollocks
it's only 10 minutes say look it's on
the ticket seven o'clock
pretty good start yeah right that's good
yeah wakey wakey I'm putting the
disasters my first night down to Lenny
having a nerve studying drink no no
tonight I'll be watching him like a hawk
to see where he's going
wrongs to one soup one ribeye an extra
portion of chips
not bad and he's actually sounding like
a proper chef
Northeast yes please and that has been
the best eight covers I've seen go out
of this kitchen
to 40 minutes of faultless control in
the kitchen
Lenny mysteriously loses it big time
this was cold and a bit tearless I
thought we'd made good progress cooking
for the family
basically just apologize for me how come
we back at square one
three four five six tickets on board
Leslie's wondering wandering around
looking for stuff to do you don't open
up and tell me what you're thinking I
can't help you could open up it's pretty
pumped it's pretty bad I'm really sorry
but goodly between our charm and the
drink is about the only thing that's
holding it up so
never seen so much food come back
something fish is going on here what's
uh
what's in there
I don't know for me no no tell me the
truth you said you're gonna be honest
this morning I've been in water and um
a vodka in the bottom when you started
off service at seven o'clock tonight
yeah it was going well you know that
there's nine o'clock and they're
starting to complain
is that because of that no that's the
first one that's come in the kitchen now
that is the truth why do you tell me you
weren't going to drink
because of absolutely you know I've been
here all day and I just wanted one drink
so I got Catherine well I do apologize
for that fair enough I'm sorry
um
service
it's all becoming seriously clear
this is not just about Lennon's lack of
confidence you let me down [__] big
time half past eight inside that [__]
cup
you sneaking vodka in
and I don't know
I don't [__] care what you do after
service
from seven o'clock to eleven you [__]
stay away from that and you put your
pressures on me
you give me the pressure
and it's not just the kitchen you're
[__] you know that you're screwing
your mum
it's gone beyond food now
Jesus
[Music]
we've hit rock bottom but Lenny's proved
to me he's got talent when he's not
drinking and he must care for his mum
and the business if he's here every
night for nothing
why does he drink
it really gets stressed and I often
wonder uh I might put them under too
much pressure
you've got to be very careful with that
because he's lost his motivation and he
has lost his Direction
so you're the only person that can turn
that around you know every time you give
him a drink in the middle of service
you're pushing the destruct button it's
you that's gonna you know close the
[__] door you can't allow him another
drink yeah
[Music]
day three at Oscars and the writings on
the wall
like many chefs Lenin finds it difficult
to cope with the stress of a busy
service unless he's had a drink when
you're in the middle of service that's
the last thing you need is a [__]
drink and I've seen my chefs trying to
do it as well in the middle of the
service by using alcohol
to get them through a very busy night
and if you haven't got your [__] wits
about you in the middle of service then
you've got no chance they can be the
most disastrous the most dangerous place
to be first thing with Lenny is to take
the pressure away starting with his
mum's deranged bit of everything menu
trying to cover everybody
and I made a pig's ear out of it can I
just say a menu that big even I wouldn't
attempt to cook
you're putting a noose around his neck
because he's not capable of doing it I
think you're more capable of doing four
or five starters four or five Mains four
or five desserts
[__] all else but for God's sake you're
both Irish so I want to have a bit of an
influence from there from the trout the
potatoes to your Irish stew and
make it sort of become a Hallmark
I want to get Lenin excited about a new
Irish theme menu let's get this fish
cake together shall we garlic butter
and show him that food can give him
these kicks instead of the booze
and hopefully they can taste the
difference between his cheap brought in
Cotton pancetta fish cake sauce get it
on there big boy and my fresh homemade
alternative
the first one that went in your mouth
was what oh
mate
and the second one that went in your
mouth was what I'll show it there
you got into it what's the first thing
the customer sees color call it fish
yeah Tales of salmon
smoke had a little bit of mustard that's
lovely
that really was nice and this place
becomes renowned for the most amazing
homemade fish cakes Christ almighty
they're a good size
going deep in
the menu's starting to come together
I just hope I'm not putting too much
pressure on Lenny too soon
are you struggling today without a drink
no I'm not doing too but no I'm not
right we're cooking and the [__] [__]
hits the fan again and we're under
pressure I don't want you going out
there no no no no guarantee you that
the restaurant relaunches in two days
time but tonight I'm trying to break
Lenny in gently we've got just 15 people
booked and it's a chance to try out some
new specials push that and push the
Irish stew and push all the specials
who's in charge of the dining room I am
you yeah I didn't feel that the other
night when I sat in here I didn't feel
like there's one person actually
controlling it I think there's two or
three things that are going wrong in the
service you really have to be strong
enough to tell them off about it they're
respect you more one final thing under
no circumstances
does anyone give this man a drink in the
middle of service is that clear mum I'm
the one who objects yeah okay good put
your foot down so true
your restaurant yeah yes your son yeah
you [__] tell him yes he'll get a
kick good
there we go the aim tonight is to teach
Lenny some control and discipline well
we've got 10 minutes before the first
customer comes you want to nip off a
quick cigarette do you mind
you wouldn't be telling me if you did
yeah I do I come back
this is the challenge you little [__]
okay every time you want to go and leave
this kitchen and disappear outside for a
cigarette
you put a pan in the Box every time I
swear I put a pan in the Box
here and that stays on there
no smoking or drinking for Lenny no
swearing for me
one loud medium to well one chicken and
ribs one portion of chips time 8 15. you
thought the pastor out Leslie Richards
are tidy up he can chop them for you
that's it now we're working like a
kitchen guys
I don't know how well Lenny's gonna fare
in this challenge
glass vodka
okay now [__] hold on hold on it's not
big start getting that full are we
starting it yes you did [__] it and
another one
yeah lazy happy yeah
let's be having your
nice and you check
check we've sent out three tables
beautifully don't start [__] up now
it's hard to break the habit of a
lifetime
[Music]
bless how long are you how far are you
away now two minutes
thank you
[Music]
in two minutes
change that thing Taylor Swift
so far so good no drinking no smoking
and the fresh fish cakes are going down
a storm
one smoked salmon party two fish cakes
cotton one cotton pancetta oh [__] that
I can't send out the decent fish cakes
with one of them cotton pancettas that's
a big move for you and I'm not trying to
make you look [__] stupid but I think
you should go and tell them that I don't
think it's something your mum should go
and do no that's your [__] kitchen
yeah okay okay come back and sell the
fish tank
where am I going
the actual special fish cakes are
homemade today and the beautiful and
I'll be honest the other ones are frozen
try them please
pride and confidence
and you spoken more here in the last two
hours that you did do for three days
last week
yeah and it sounds fantastic right and
you sound in control
and you look bloody good
thank you
Linens proved he can get through on a
quiet night without his usual
distractions
smoke some fennel seeds or
here you go just try it try it try this
is therapy go and try it
[Music]
it's not mine actually
I'm now smoking asparagus and it tastes
[__] delicious
I enjoyed it it's nice to see that
standard of food going out and it's nice
to see it going nice and smooth and not
coming back
so I'll sleep tonight this time I'm sure
I will all right let's get tidy down
ahead we're making great Headway in the
kitchen now I can work on Mora I'm
making it perfect for the customers
first problem
finding the place
that looks fantastic
huh lovely yes lovely lovely you'll
never get a better advertising space
than that fresh home cooking with an
Irish flavor upstairs that's lovely I'm
glad you've got the flower boxes done as
well it looks like there's something up
there now hopefully that should help get
some more bums on seats upstairs
second problem
to win back Oscar's reputation by
creating a midweek bargain it's a small
close-knit town here nantwich so you've
got to install confidence back in the
locals and now is the time to turn it
around
14 pounds not too cheap you can make
money on 14 pounds for two courses if
you can do that Tuesday Wednesday
Thursday with 30 customers a night 90
covers
at 30 quid ahead you know it's four and
a half thousand
pound in the till
no I like that and everything's fresh
next problem good food at a bargain
price isn't worth anything without good
service we have to bond we have to gel
there's not enough teamwork going on in
here work with your customers and work
with your Chef stagger the tickets
coming through great understanding and
make sure we've got great communication
if they get it right then they'll also
help to take pressure off the kitchen
to well one chicken and ribs one portion
of chips
time Lenin gets off to a good start
but he seems a bit more stressed and
sounds less confident
you're right Lenny you've gone quiet on
me hey no fight
but evidently he wasn't later that
evening events took a terrible turn
[Music]
Lenin collapsed he's been rushed to
hospital in an ambulance and I hope the
hell is okay it was a [__] shock
[Music]
I need to know what's going on it seems
Lenin's drinking has aggravated his
health problems
and I wish that I got told the tooth
when we first met
and I felt he's put an amazing Brave
face on and he's he's stuck in there but
you know when I heard the problem last
night with the drink his medical
condition and the problem with his liver
you know and I was shocked on the back
of trying to deal with that yeah I
thought Lennon had told you
I feel like you're not being honest with
me
but I am a garden everything's
everything's head for me I don't know
yeah
I didn't know and it seems even more
isn't aware of the extent of his
problems Lily hello
yeah yeah am I pleased to see you
how you feeling
better than last night anyway [__]
everybody you scared me last night
I'm just amazed that you didn't want to
sort of share it with me early on
because I I would have rather known yeah
it was more embarrassment nothing to
embarrassment I just wish I knew when we
first met that you had that problem yeah
it's got nothing to be embarrassed about
I'm sorry [__] all to be embarrassed
about your health and your condition
makes far more important that restaurant
you know that yeah
Conker around like this I know that
uh before he goes anywhere near a
kitchen yeah he's got to get himself
better and clearly start looking after
himself before any of that takes place
the family I've got to start talking to
each other so they can [__] help him
using alcohol as a crutch in the kitchen
is a problem that can't be ignored to
better understand Lenin's problems I've
contacted pioneering Chef Michael Quinn
thanks so much for coming over Michael
set up the Art Foundation to tackle the
industry-wide problem of alcohol and
drug abuse after he himself was toppled
by the demon drink we had the perfect
job for [__] sake the first ever
British chef to be crowned
the chef de cuisine at the Ritz hotel
absolutely when I left the race I was at
the top of the tree an alcohol just
completely took over my life yeah I went
from the Ritz eventually to living on
the street I slept on the bridges in
doorways you know I was in hospital with
liver failure the last rise from a
Catholic priest when when that close
yeah why do chefs today think it's part
of a [__] rock and roll image to
drink our business as chefs is a very
tough uh it's a tough business the
immensely long hours we do the Heat and
also that that you know you're almost
part of an sas student in the kitchen
it's our workout plaid will show the
rest of the bastards how good we are but
one in ten across that line and if you
cross that line into addition into
becoming an alcoholic you can never go
back to social drinking then this guy
continue to cook and deal with a problem
at the same time no no it needs to be
separated will power doesn't get you
well in order to recover you need to
surrender and admit defeat and that is
the step forward to Freedom
Michael's an extreme case but Lennon
needs to take a lesson from this and nip
his drinking Habit in the bud before
it's too late
we're all upset about Lenin but tonight
sees the launch of our new menu and the
show must go on everything
on this [__] menu here is fresh and
the sad thing is I wish Lenny was here
to cook it
but I think what we do for tonight's
service is owe this one to him yeah I
think that sounds like the first
customers let's go
with Lenin out of action it's Bingo
caller Les to the rescue and he's
nervous as hell right Les how are you
doing
you're sweating yeah yes good it's a
healthy sign when you sweat so you stand
on the hot plane you call out and you
tell me what you want doing Gordon Rams
is going to be your [__] comic go
Ease on it a little bit fragile okay
yeah run it through your mind first yeah
and bingo
eyes down for a full house
one broth one asparagus yeah sure
[Music]
gently nice and gently careful when
you're putting the ball please yeah the
idea is not to Splash it everywhere yeah
every time that's staying there Les he
just [__] up violent against Stone
Cold he's off to a shaky start but this
is his first time running a kitchen stop
stop come on layers [__] what do you
want them to floss with a [__] Clint
film come on go please give me a little
toss I'm sure you're good at tossing
come on watch those eyebrows
golden shouts too much
still not leading her team in the dining
room doesn't get too good food always
gets tips they need to be inspired we're
at the table charm them
come on there's
happy yep good there you go cross them
off please in the kitchen things are
looking up
two cabbage one piece three Mash yeah
sure this is fantastic it's absolutely
[__] amazing but the one thing
letting Les down is Maura's lack of
discipline in front of house the last
order yeah one of the girls forgot to
take the main course out and that's what
I said earlier about how the diamonds
really got to [__] wake up a little
bit it's not funny sweetheart no you're
not what I'm trying to say yeah we have
got to get it together end of story yeah
Quick Service the numbers are really
coming in for Less tonight everybody
okay outside everybody's enjoying the
food great glitch for coming back please
you're doing a good job thank you very
much I'm not a great meat eater but this
is brilliant it's lovely I went for the
ribeye steak which was superb food
tonight was gorgeous really really nice
yeah we've done a [__] good job
everyone was expecting him to sing from
the crack and to disappear and [__] off
back to college but uh he's done himself
proud I think more importantly than
Lenny proud the fact that everything's
gone out brilliantly
and smoothly you know
and the fact that it's spent all day
preparing it and from fresh
so why I became a chef really good
feedback customers the last tip we got
was the 1850.
18 pound fifty yeah yeah fantastic you
know some some mistakes tonight that
they're really a problem but they're so
easily sorted that's just communication
you know you're not good at disciplining
stuff
if that's what you think uh you show
you've proved to me
I've never heard you shout never heard
you tell anyone off because when this
business closes they will go off and
look for a new job
and if you're going to maximize in your
dreams sweetheart and keep this place
open you so so so have to get on top
your business
and your money
before I go
I just want you all for 30 seconds to
close your eyes
unless it's just going to read off some
numbers give it to me Big Boy eyes down
looking Les is done number 10.
so if that lead is 88 all the legs
eleven anyway round 69. all credit to
him unless it's pulled it off tonight
fantastic but he's only a novice good
night and Lennon needs rest and time to
recover before he even considers
stepping foot in a kitchen again if
Moore was going to stand any chance of
getting Oscars back on track she needs
to find a new chef and fast
[Music]
it's been a month since I spent a week
at Oscars and it was one hell of a week
the food was so bad the customers came
once but never returned
the head chef lacked respect for the
place I'd say get [__] is mum the
owner was that a Wit's End I just I
can't carry on necklace much longer
Lennon smoked and drank the job
I just wanted one drink but we worked
through it
don't start [__] up now and the new
Irish menu was looking great food
tonight was gorgeous
collapsed he's been rushed to hospital
in an ambulance and I hope the hell is
okay
after a break Lennon's back in the
kitchen and I'm here to find out how
he's doing thank you we got some color
on your face you look Brown yeah drink
wise
are you seeing someone that's yeah I am
actually I've been to my doctor and I've
been everything sorted out a couple of
bad days here and there but
um the majority good most important
thing you do something about you know
that because that's not fair on you and
that's not fair mum and it's not fair in
the restaurant when are you having a
drink after service before service what
are you doing
before
um
anytime now
99.9 after service
possibly sometimes don't even bother and
just go home and get them in bed get all
separating out big to menus and just
messing about it over here are you
eating properly oh God yeah I'm eating
no I can't stop eating at the moment
well you're not exactly [__] fat are
you there it is turn around let me show
you pop a tummy yeah that's what you
call a [__] trip listen Big Boy ah
he's [__] eating properly
I'm all right thank you good to see you
is he up to the job of actually running
it full time
hi Murphy not certain no no oh it's all
right
but it's it's
drinking and uh kitchens and stoves
don't go together do they no lethal
combination
Moore's Keen to take the burden away
from Lenin she's lined up a potential
new head chef but Lennon's not happy
about it
I mean I've watched meal restaurants
um since I was a child
I wanted to be my dad
um
and now that it's here
I do have that fear that it's going to
be taken away from me no one's getting
rid of it I understand what you're
saying yeah I'm trying to think of a way
forward so we can benefit and keep this
place alive and and and keep your mom's
dream and her ambition you cannot
continue like this you know that it's
going to kill you and a new Chef I think
is a breath of fresh air about you know
so can we kiss and make up and let's
meet this [__] chef
huh
thank you
[Music]
Mark Warrington is a fully trained chef
with an impressive CV
but can he cook with anything you wish
wonder she's fine yeah
[Music]
come through and well it looks a little
bit more [__] Chinese than it does
the Irish to me the fish is but the rest
of it
for the potatoes are Irish yeah the fish
is cooked nice shoes lovely yeah it's
quite interesting seeing you guys
bonding there
um
learning me basically we can bounce
ideas off one another well seeing in the
kitchen
looks like we found our Man Mark starts
his new job at Oscars next week
but tonight
is Leonard's chance to shine
[Music]
everything that you know is fresh it's
got to go out a bit of a surprise for
you tonight I haven't told any of you
I've got 10 very important customers
coming it's the 10 customers they're
absolutely fuming the first night I had
dinner here big [__] knife now on top
of that they're going to be presented
with this
there's an Oscar's Restaurant loyalty
card and is to inspire them to return to
the restaurant
and on their sixth visit they'll come as
our guests look out for them yeah
this evening Moore is hosting an Irish
night if it's going to run smoothly The
Waitresses must be Keen as well as green
and are you in control yes yeah good
remember last time that wasn't that
impressive service you know that and
tonight I'm gonna be all over the
service you know like a rash yeah whose
kitchen is this Mike do you want me to
stand back yes if you don't mind not
interfere yeah so I'll stand back all
right let's dance yeah what about
[__] dancing
but I can't [__] dance
I've seen nothing I've got to be honest
you look like
the menu of Irish tube and pork and
Guinness is in physically right for
Oscar's new Irish theme
first order party soup in the garlic
mushrooms and two fish cake two three
potatoes
[Music]
yep yep
and the restroom's full so the
waitresses have got to give it their
best just slow the girls down a little
bit get them walking a little bit
gracefully like ladies yeah not like
baby elephants
Lennon's food seems to be hitting the
spot
s to what I've had tonight big miles of
high really the plates are consistently
coming back empty but I thought Bingo
called might have shown a bit more
Pizzazz Les you're a big softer you know
that
push them out of the way take some
pressure off him and be strong big
softie don't make good Cooks I don't
want to [__] hear that you've turned
into a [__] dinner lady yeah or
you're working for [__] Jamie Oliver
it's been a good night for Leonard but
I'm pleased he's got a chef to help him
through
[Music]
maybe more as iostream will come true
after all
right
[Music]
[Applause]
one last thing 15 Stone chests with size
14 feet Don't Dance
[Music]
I think I'll lead into it
how many people does it take to run a
small Seaside hotel and restaurant
I've never seen so many [__] managers
supervisors head receptionists and Sous
chefs I'm absolutely gobsmacked in this
week's nightmares I check into a real
life Faulty Towers to find out
a porn movie
I can't physically test everything
within the kitchen or I'll end up like a
big air balloon I would have thought
[Music]
[__] wake up William yeah
wake up
foreign
[Music]
hotel is perched on the gorgeous stretch
of the Kent Coast
it's 24 miles from France but a million
miles from being a good hotel and
restaurant
a sandgate hotel
[Music]
what a great spot
it's got 15 rooms and a covered in AA
rosette for its food and I'm checking in
first test of any hotel is the reception
always a great sign of Harry's run
I mean
it's cool about five minutes ago hello
[Music]
you're on the phone yeah
no let's get into it I'm going tell him
he's a customer
number four thank you
three years ago Lois and Peter Hamilton
Slade pulled their life savings and
bought the sand gate
at the moment this place is losing
around two grand a week so Peter has had
to keep his engineering job while Lois
runs a hotel and restaurant
[Music]
you've obviously run restaurants before
no no never never or small guest houses
then no never never this is our first
first
this is the restaurant oh it's very
small isn't it yes very small Lois has
gone from selling perfume at Gatwick
Airport to managing this small boutique
hotel by the Sea and the food come
waiter
husband and wife team running a hotel
and a dumb waiter
that must be a nightmare
it seems to work very well does it yeah
extraordinarily it's not just one
restaurant there's also a Terrace
barbecue a bar and Ken's first Japanese
restaurant in the basement it's a
strange mix but they do have one thing
in common no customers
how long can it survive if we don't have
a very
good summer
all I don't think we'll get through
them but if she hits the fan and it
doesn't take place and we have a crap
summer
um would you lose
probably a quarter of a million
what's that the food is inconsistent I
think that is a lot of the case when
Stewart's not here it's just the head
the Japanese Chef where's he from
38 from Northumberland he's been here
for six months it's his first head
Chef's job but since he's got here he
started hearing voices
my little system of uh communication is
it like that all night yeah
how did you concentrate with that try to
ignore as much as possible
okay now
it's not driving around the bend yeah
yeah is that order for table nine yeah
oh hello nine yeah
four restaurants
168 dishes and one kitchen time to taste
the food okay thank you and they're the
this is the specials yes
Japanese menu as well please of course
you can thank you
tonight Saturday night
so just to let you know we don't
actually serve Japanese in this
restaurant just just okay
um so I'll go downstairs my staff don't
come back here for a main course
um I need to see the effect for the
marriage manager see what I can do for
you food beverage manager yes
[Music]
I mean what a way of pissing Customs off
food and beverage yeah okay so you
really want me to go downstairs
that's what I've been told by the
general manager and who's that that's
Kirstie
thank you very much
[Music]
we've got three managers two waitresses
but only four customers the numbers just
don't add up
[Music]
the rice is hard what a [__] up
well it's not the only one
next chicken from the a la carte menu
thank you because we're not supposed to
have a porn movie
it's enough to make your eyes water
excuse me waitress I'm missing my
bullets
um
doesn't taste the chicken it takes off
tomato it's like sun-dried tomatoes
running through it but they're so so
strong not for me
[Music]
the Mackie rolls who made them
how old are you 18 18. so you don't
taste anything that this 18 year old
cook I can't physically taste everything
within the kitchen or I'll end up like a
big air balloon I would have thought
I like the
I like I like to to obviously taste as
much as I can
a head chef who doesn't taste his food
is asking for trouble I've never seen
anyone cut it before
it's the only way to maintain control
and keep up standards
plenty time
I think the rice is on the door thank
you that's all it's really important for
United obviously it's down the level
like I said you can you can see I'm not
Japanese
I'm not trying to dig a hole and try and
Escape for before you associate that was
uh
I've still gotten my teeth
[Music]
Stuart doesn't want to cook Japanese
food the
don't want to eat Japanese food so why
in the hell have they got a Japanese
restaurant this place doesn't know what
it's doing and that's clearly down to
one thing bad management
[Music]
Lois has got more managers than the race
but I can't work out who's running this
place and I've got a sneaky feeling no
one else can either
the business is in danger of closing I
don't think you actually know how dire
the situation is the amount of
management and the amount of staff in
such a small place I've never seen in my
entire life
you know that
I've never been so confused with
supervisors and managers and head
receptionists you're running this hotel
like a 350 bedroom 5 Star Deluxe and the
most important one is no one seems to be
controlling it I've come up with an
exercise to try and find out who is in
charge drop this Stone
in the bucket or the person you think is
the control of the sand Gate Hotel
the whole organization the whole
organization
oh dear he's gone past all the managers
and ignored Lois okay
next Luca the restaurant manager
surely he must know
he just picked the head receptionist
next up is Kevin the food and beverage
manager
I have most dogs
that's what I'm trying to get through
now that's the problem everybody is
running it and there's no one
controlling it the voice on the top yep
thank you
and you hit the nail on the head that's
what's exactly [__] happening
everybody's trying to run it and they're
not doing their own jobs
so interesting we're all here now and
there's five of you that have got stones
in your buckets
so already there's a conflicted message
if this business is to survive Lois
needs to take command of it
she's got a few stones but she's got no
bollocks
if she doesn't grow a pair the hotel is
going to be washed up
[Music]
the Sango hotel in Kent has lost 33 000
pounds in the first four months of this
year but while Rome Burns Lois and Peter
the owners seem determined to eat drink
and be merry male after meal after meal
my brief when I started was it's run
like Lawson Peter's living room and
that's how they wanted it
that's basically what I was told was
run it as if it's their Lounge
basically
running a hotel and restaurant is not
the same as eating and drinking in one
Lois and Peter brought a dream now they
need to wake up to the fact that it's a
business not a second home
day three at sandgate towers and a
chance to see the Terrace Barbie
[__] you know hardly a day for a [__]
barbecue I feel like I'm a [__] car
boot sale
Stewart's worked in some good kitchens
in his career but they get him to set up
a portable Barbie it's heartbreaking
you don't get any customers today I will
say why isn't that [__] thing surely
they can't make their head chef suffer
anymore like the kitchen
ah
kitchen are you there
are we all set
uh give us a
oh four minutes on a bison garnish
please
where's that to Kelly
this place is like a jigsaw but none of
the pieces fit
three setup so he's out there on the
barbecue and you're left to run the
kitchen
[__] out your 20 years of age you're
18 years of age I mean how come you've
got all that responsibility
and what happens when it's busy
who would put someone who's clearly a
good Chef in charge of a barbecue time
to find out from the manager but which
one
Kirsty how are you the general manager
is Lois's daughter-in-law
before coming to Britain she worked in
restaurants in her native New Zealand
the barbecue
um my aim was
kiwi barbecue
I thought that
sort of territorial kiwi Beach life
something like that yeah but sweetheart
we're not in [__] Auckland
the lack of focus in this place is
astounding Lois hasn't even got her
Flagship fine dining restaurant under
control
the majority of the complaints
that come through are normally on your
day off have you ever eaten in the
restaurant no because if the complaints
are going on when you're not here you've
got to see what they're serving in the
dining room so you can really do
something about it properly yeah and
identify are we too complicated is the
menu too big are they inexperienced do
we need to simplify what does what do I
need to do as a head chef
how can you relate to your customers
experience if you're not experienced in
the same time go upstairs order I think
you'll find something very interesting
going on there
Kirsty hasn't worked at the sharp end of
the business for about eight months so
today she's going to waitress
ing what's on and what's up but I'm sure
you do student number two in the kitchen
is 21 year old Johnny
so what's going first Johnny I'm going
to sit in this bathroom first and then
the starters the bread's just gone up to
the two but I can't find anyone to take
it out the libyans
Johnny runs the kitchen two days a week
when Stewart's off
this is my chance to see how he copes
come on guys 10 minutes we're [__]
around with a gun they're a young team
to be cooking such elaborate food yeah
I'm just about to Johnny they ordered it
over one hour ago yeah yeah let's get it
out guys come on
[Music]
I'm not gonna allow you to send them
this is really important for you you
know that from a focal point of view
because you've got to go all the way up
to the top of this [__] industry not
serving [__] like that big boy I know
what you're doing by serving that [__]
is
destroying the place
and that's just on a [__] Burger
and I know you can do better than that
you know that I Know I Can Do Better
there you go so [__] do it yeah
there are only nine customers in for
lunch
but it's well over an hour before Stuart
and Kevin get their mains
unfortunately Kevin and Stewart aren't
the only unhappy customers
[__] wake up William yeah
wake up
he's one of the worst lunch Services
I've ever seen Johnny's tried his best
but the real culprit is clear
it's Stewart's food
it's just far too complicated
say the least Stewart's had a shock
upstairs too
I actually walked up he walked out yeah
[__] why did he walk out because I
seen someone else eating my desserts but
I'd been waiting for 35 minutes
a head chef walking out of his own
restaurant this place is sunk about as
low as it can go
morning
how are you
[Music]
Stuart seen firsthand what's wrong
upstairs I think the best people tell
him what's wrong downstairs are his own
Brigade but I think the young chefs like
this soft-hearted Jordy so much they've
been too afraid to pipe up in case they
hurt his feelings it's time they told
their boss a few home truths so whoever
catches the bass today
as you catch that verse you turn around
openly and tells Stewart something
you've got a lot to say haven't you
I do
[__] me big boy
here we go
come on
[Music]
um
more important we've got to say all
right Steve quickly because Luke's in
you've got a lovely menu but there's too
much to it
I just think that the menu is nice and
there's just I think there's too many
garnishes really for the dishes
thanks for telling us that's all it is
really
about 38 Stuart's old to have just got
his first head Chef's job
if we simplify it I think we can get the
taste a lot better and we can get the
stuff looking so much better instead of
having to try and rush it out all the
time I just don't like the service being
manic because I know that I can do
better myself and I know the rest of us
can
great they're starting to enjoy
themselves team spreads vital to a good
kitchen
[Applause]
[Music]
the only one pissed off is me four hours
on the English Channel and I didn't
catch a thing
sandgate is twined with songout a French
Town 24 miles across the channel
but instead of seeking inspiration from
France Lois and Kirsty have got their
chefs cooking food from New Zealand and
Japan six thousand miles away
[Music]
my plan is to bring them home save us
you're not going to get any better any
fresher quality ingredients than that
it's on your doorstep that's what I want
you to take advantage of let's do it sea
bass fish on the a la carte menu has 15
ingredients which is why the boys
struggles so much with it we're going to
show them a simpler version with just
five ingredients and then just let the
knife do the work
sure
and
back on the stove I think what I'm
trying to do is just show you how easy
you can but one person can do this
narrow down the complexity of it and it
can be done within three or four minutes
you know that yeah
see Bass
and the dish is going to be just as
exciting with less on there because
we're concentrating on the sea bass
being hot the dish being less complex
and flavor
Lois has been guilty of putting
unrealistic demands on the Stewart no
chef with a small team can cook 168
dishes really well we've got to convince
her and Peter that less is more
absolutely amazing
the sea bass has won them over but
there's bad news which sadly had a
letter this morning to say that we've
lost our A.A Rose end yep
so it was for the food guide right
one a a rosette is awarded for food come
with care and skill
but forced to cook for four restaurants
Stu has slipped below that standard
there's a kick in the bollocks for any
chef don't know toys about that but in a
way it's a clean start you turn the page
we make it less complex and we go again
[Music]
we haven't got long to turn this place
around and I'm worried I don't know if
The Big Friendly Giant will be able to
pick himself up from this one
[Music]
wrong they're taking it away
I'm gutted
what can we do
it's a kick in the teeth it's a it's a
bullet to the heart
if Lois isn't careful it won't just be
Stewart's Professional Pride down the
pan
less is more on the plate and in the
hotel we need to simplify everything so
what's left comes Sparkle
the weakest link is the Japanese
restaurant how's it going
going so going up and down up and down
it's costing more to staff than it's
making last week it took just 290 pounds
I'm personally worried about it and what
about you
uh
I think we're in love with the idea more
than we are with the success of the
business and my idea is to close it
and to stop hemorrhaging money what
would you suggest
here I think you've got a perfect room
for a private dining an over spill from
the restaurant that's a good idea it's a
fantastic idea and I think whether he's
got the bollocks to tell you or not I'm
going to tell you he's not very
comfortable cooking it he's not a
[__] Japanese Chef he's a Geordie
[Music]
I put the food back on the road to
recovery and got rid of that stupid
Japanese but front of house is still a
shambles hello and when did your book
um when we arrived this evening oh okay
no problems well I do have some space
for you okay but I don't have your money
sorry sorting out the chaotic customer
service is too much even for me
puzzle 40 wouldn't like it but what this
place needs is a Frenchman [__] me am I
happy to see you are you well I'm very
well yeah I'd like to introduce you to
Jean Baptiste please my major league
from claritus John Baptist is in charge
of 70 waiters if there's anyone who can
help Lois organize the restaurant it's
him
um right let's have a look at the um
he'll take control upstairs one I help
Stewart keep things chip shaped
downstairs
in the kitchen and to the restaurant so
the customer's Gonna Hear The Waitresses
talking the restaurant manager talking
and the buzzer also there you go it goes
right through the dining room
thank you when the first
within minutes of arriving Jean-Baptiste
bans the intercom system from now on the
waiters will have to go downstairs and
talk to the chefs face to face
even the basics aren't looked after here
Luca the restaurant manager hasn't got
enough cold water for lunch yeah because
you're going to run out of whatever
quickly my friend
but what I will do I would be an
accomplice with us
lemon
they're too warm unfortunately
unfortunately how are you going to do
that look at those glasses they're
[__] dirty look at that
all right this is what we need to change
the account
we have to be customer orientated okay
front of house I've had absolutely no
leadership or quality control from Lois
of course
you are the Winger okay you get the
restaurant manager you've got some water
to bring the moon okay while you're here
you're here to be here facing the
customers welcome okay welcome home you
know
Welcome Home the first check is in
[Music]
clear face-to-face communication like
this should cut out all the wrong orders
and misunderstanding
okay that was difficult
what's it like having the tickets in the
kitchen now in your hands
yeah
that's [__] bad guys look hello yeah
no one touches that [__] thing okay
who's gonna do it
okay
it works in here so what do you mean
walking here the stuff is
a member of Staff ignoring Lois and
heading for the bar and she hasn't
battled an eyelid what's going on you're
the [__] owner not even say hello to
you can you believe that
um
it's a bad organization it's a lack of
communication a lack of a teammate team
spirit team leader nobody knows what
they're doing
um the the waiter is managing the the
owner the owner doesn't know what she's
doing and it's
has helped reorganize the restaurant
but he's also uncovered the ultimate
symptom of everything that's wrong with
Lois's business
staff are allowed to drink on the
premises
I need to get to the bottom of this
they spend a lot of money in they spend
over 2 000 pounds a month on the bar 2
000 pounds a month
[__] me
500 quid a week on staff drinks that's
what they spend have you become
dependent on that
possibly
I guess to a degree we sat down and
looked at you know how much we were
earning off of them at the end of the
day
you know it reduces the celery though
it's even worse than I thought
because her on Earth
are you going to get the message across
when you're treading on eggshells to not
upset them because they're going to be
spending two thousand pound a month in
the bar [__] you now I've never heard
anything so pathetic in all my life
everyone's taking the piss and maybe
there is an advantage of having too many
staff because they're spending 2 000
pounds a month in the [__] bar
drinking and clearly that's keeping the
business afloat
oh
[Music]
the sangai hotel in Kent is in serious
trouble it's got a great location and a
great chef but I know no hasn't got a
clue how to run a business I mean the
midst of trying to rescue it [__]
wake up William yeah
wake up
in just two days time we're relaunching
the restaurant with a French flavor
we're holding an oyster eating
competition against a French team from
some gas
but I've discovered that owner Lois and
her manager Kirsty are getting the
basics wrong they allow their staff to
use the bar as a common room which is a
Surefire way to drive your customers
away
we have done it wrong I do I can
absolutely see it but we have done it
wrong
building up it's getting more and more
familiar they're more and more drinking
game and sometimes people there's so
many stuff the customers can't get to
the bar
the staff are spending over 24 Grand a
year on booze and [__] but I'm putting a
stop to it now once you've finished your
shift I'm afraid you cannot
that is massive
this business is not run for staff and
the owners no longer depend on you guys
putting money in behind the bar and
secondly you've got no idea of the
conflicting messages it's sending to the
customers and you can't serve a member
of the public and then go and sit in the
same bar and drink with them it's not
good never seen it in my entire life and
it's got to stop this is not a drinking
hole this is not a socializing gas can I
just ask whether when you say stuff out
of drink does that mean their days off
as well why does anyone want to come
here on their day off let me tell you
why because it's too [__] easy let's
go down the sand gate let's sit there
and get bladdered let's sit on the
Terrace let's sit it's too comfy having
you got homes to go to has this become
too convenient I think we can all agree
that then when there's asses to be
kicked the next day and disciplinary to
take place no one wants to listen to the
owners or Kirsty because we've sort of
had a chat and had a drink over it and
nothing's done if this place has got any
hope of surviving and going from
strength to strength to identify the
customers are more important staff that
has to stop cheers let's get back to
work we're going to have to be very
careful as well because you know there
is a tendency to come in here and you
know lots and Peter meet up and here at
the end of the day and you know have a
drink together we're I guess to a degree
we're going to have to leave by example
at last someone's talking about leading
it's not Lois but I think we're getting
somewhere
equipment
but I'm still worried about Stuart since
he lost the A.A rosette his morale has
hit rock bottom
to have any chance of pulling off the
relaunch I need the Geordie giant back
from the Dark Side regarding the
Accolade yeah [__] get it back and
and get it back properly without trying
to cook 168 dishes get it back cooking a
menu that you can control
why'd you shout so much
I'm going to help him devise a new menu
that's right for a Seaside Hotel
focusing on fresh fish with a French
twist if I came to sit in the bar or
you'd sit in a restaurant here I'd love
a bowl of milk for it here I'd love a
platterfield America I'll die for it you
know why because I can relate to the
food because there's the [__] seat oh
it's ideal like this here I mean oh you
know and and price wise as well yeah uh
ideally look at it to buy fresh fish so
basically next to nothing
foreign
[Music]
across that channel to get in here
yeah a nice big Sumptuous Rich pear
tatan pears from Kent bring a little bit
of [__] England meets France France
meets England yeah
with sugar there oh right oh Donnie
smell like the cardamom seeds that's
lovely
okay
um
as well as a new menu we also need new
customers
so Saga the biggest employer in town
with nearly a thousand workers just
around the corner from the restaurant is
Saga look sort of arms with two dozen
oysters we've come to turn them on for
fresh seafood
very nice delicious anything happening
downstairs
all the produce as local fish but you
can see from the Sandia Hotel the same
with the oysters
it's good to start talking about other
things in the menu the idea of just
getting them to sort of up to speed with
the oysters is for you then to sort of
let them know about everything else yeah
it's essential the Russian attracts
locals who are still around when the
tourists go home these are the people
who keep the business afloat in the
winter
a question
I said nice lovely and there's an added
bonus for you
we've got the most amazing bedrooms
upstairs if things are good
word of mouth is best publicity you can
get in the restaurant trade and
hopefully we've just set a thousand tons
wagging
it's not a large
it's on menu with two sizes
Lois is front of house team are still
flapping she treats him like her
extended family and seems afraid to
discipline them it's got to change and
I've been racking my brains out all
[__] week I've had Lois and get
really strong with her staff and I've
got a little idea
[__] you now
just one of them one of them
no that's gonna be terrible greasy
[__]
assertiveness training Chef style the
photos really
tell him exactly what you think of him
Luca I think you're an extremely nice
person and you're an asset to the place
she's more like mum than matron like I
own it you have got to have respect for
me and I don't think you have yeah I
think with him you've got to get really
to the point so I'm not gonna put that
there
Luca every time I want something you do
it dudes you're told or look for a new
[__] job
to say [__] it's a chef's thing far
away
Luca is time that you learned I cannot
put up with you interrupting me all the
time I'm not doing what I ask you if you
work for me I do not work for you good
much better Chef every time I speak to
you you interrupt me it's absolutely
gobsmacking and it's incredibly Bad
Manners Kevin you'll come steaming in
and interrupt and start talking over the
top of me do not do it now we're getting
somewhere I need respect from everybody
listen to what I'm telling you and for
Christ's sake get on with it good do you
feel any better yeah it's lovely isn't
it do
[Music]
let's go
absolutely
[Music]
when I said to you last night that
Cynthia was to do the ladies in the bar
immediately you said to me Cynthia
mustn't do the ladies in the Bible just
like me and Kevin coordinating the
function then you coming breaking in
without instructions it's gonna be so
many people giving instructions that's
what I'm here to do I have to control it
Luca basically in a nutshell just do
what she says sure and if you've got an
issue with it talk to her after service
we're in the middle of service do what
she says yeah okay I must must be heard
and taken like this off okay good thank
you
Lois has finally discovered her inner
chef and not a moment too soon
end the story
[Music]
a few hours time we relaunched the
restaurant
and this menu
yeah it's clear straightforward it can
be eaten in the restaurant it can be
eaten on the Terrace and it can be eaten
in the bar
60 of the area's most influential people
are coming for lunch so the chefs will
need to pull together like a team
I've got here for you guys the most
amazing jackets spotless guess what
we're going to do before we put those
jackets on
go on
we're going in the sea exactly we're
gonna have a quick dip before lunch
who's up for it
[Music]
here we go
[Applause]
oh
with great Seafood on the menu the first
will arrive naturally enough for the
French welcome to sandgate Hotel Miss
the theme that the chefs are taking on
in the Oyster shocking competition after
lunch and it looks like they've all been
in training
excuse me one one tuna
[Music]
with the first orders in the kitchen
swings into action
that looks beautiful very nice it's all
in the Hat yeah what a transformation
from a week ago the food's simple the
chefs are calm collected and working as
a team
[Music]
but for Lois and her waiters upstairs
it's a different story
it's going pear-shaped
upstairs all my guys have came in early
they're cracking Dawn we have time to go
up on a swim
we are time to go for a swim before
service but I tell you what I know who's
swimming now
I think we're about to sing
I need to find out what's happening and
stop the rods
another wrong order means more work for
the chefs we've got to cook the salmon
again though haven't we yeah
if it's a table of six we can understand
but one table of two is ordered wrong
come on what's the noise
glass everywhere maybe to start the
paper again
and to top it all the general manager is
having a drink on the Terrace and Lois
hasn't stopped her what is going on
it's 1 30 coming up
um just out of Interest why can't Kirsty
jump in and give us a hand on such a big
day no disrespect we're having drinks
with her mates you know a day like today
what kind of mess is that serving
because can you help out no one's taking
care of the Terrace one table's already
left because they wouldn't have their
order taken we just need General help
yeah I'll just
and these poor men out here still
waiting for their main course yeah to go
and Chase that one
everyone should be hands on [__] dick
now you know that yeah a week ago it was
pandemonium down here and football
happening upstairs now it's pandemonium
upstairs and everything's happening here
you know that two wives does natural
what noise does deep fried two prawns
Lois is finally getting control front of
house
cracking the whip with her staff and
getting them working like a team
for the first time in a week the
customer's been put first
yeah
what an improvement
[Laughter]
it's very nice to see more fish on the
menu particularly as we're here to the
Sea I'm enjoying it very much I love all
my India on both sides of the channel
that is only what is left because come
on be in French we have to talk out of
it I feel like a millionaire
it's Stu and the chefs have pulled it
off oh thanks for these guys as well
now they've faced the French team in the
oyster eating competition
special events that get the restaurant
noticed and talked about are a great way
to bring in more custom welcome to the
first ever Sunday versus songats oyster
shopping competition
hey
hey which in five minutes you're gonna
have to have to open and eat as many
oysters as possible
if Lowe's and Peter can make this an
annual competition it will help improve
anglo-frange relations and do their rest
from a power of Good Into The Bargain
one minute to go
[Music]
28 for the fridge
excuse me please and Peter for the
Sunday English how many please
[Applause]
Jesus she's trying to drag me back to
France
[Music]
[Applause]
today's been a great launch pad for the
restaurant now it's up to Lois to take
the place forward and run it like a
business not like a living room stand up
with them yeah
I saw it a week ago thinking God you
know you may own the place but you're
not running it yeah you've got to run it
and own it
big difference yeah and don't fall in
love with it because it's a job quiet
yeah you've got to keep at them on them
and at them and on them and at them
but for my money Stuart's the hero when
he lost his rosette earlier this week I
thought I'd lost him but all credit to
him he's pulled it round
you deserve to make it yours stick to
what you know you can do properly and
stand firm on that one hey you still
look like Jimmy now I was at the doors
or the accent of the accent yeah
gives us something wild beer and Spirits
[Music]
they've got six weeks until I come back
I hope they're still singing then
foreign
at the beginning of the summer I spent a
week at the Sangeet Hotel
it couldn't work out if it was a comedy
or a tragedy
please I simplified the food got the
owner to run the place like a business I
must must be heard and take an actress
off okay I made a splash at the relaunch
six weeks later
back
[Music]
good morning
how are you
how are you I'm very well thank you
hello that's a good sign hello Gordon
are you well I'm well thanks yes here's
what I caught earlier
good to see you both
um is he downstairs yep
yeah what you mean [__] hell that's
not a nice reception how are you very
well huh how are you yeah we put it in
the fridge and we'll have a uh we'll
have a chat about that later but last
time I was here the staff was spending
two grand a month in the bar and before
I banned it Stuart was one of the worst
offenders what have you been spending
your money on per month that you're not
spending upstairs in the bar decided to
go out there and have a little baby man
no yeah that's fantastic yeah it's been
spared in what too much time at home
see what happens huh that's great news
in the kitchen he's got a new system to
tell the waiters upstairs when the food
is ready explain it to me it's a
vibrating system a vibrating system so
if it's uh we're at a number one yeah
well then press the number one button it
gives them a little tickle all the
waiters are working with vibrators
that's fantastic yeah huh yeah and any
waitresses need more sort of jigs than
any of that yeah yeah I mean if they're
doing if it doesn't come out I just give
them all the tickle like this
one thing very interesting that
um the customers that come now yes are
not the people that we had before that's
totally different it's been an amazing
which is a great year this week yeah
that's really fantastic it's great to
see Lois and Peter moving the business
forward with new customers and new ideas
um we've had the two move from
downstairs when we closed when when you
were here when we closed down we had
someone do all rewiring and put this
[__] in here but crucially how's the new
menu doing
now if the boys told you but on Friday
we sold out of seafood 40 covers on
Tuesday and 50 covers on Wednesdays so
you know selling out of seafood you know
we never used to do that
can the business survive
if it continues going on like this now
yes since it was last here turnovers
nearly doubled to 14 and a half Grand a
week so they must be getting something
right
time to find out for myself let's have a
look at the
um Bar menu but I'm not going in there
to be oh no you can eat in here it's
fine wow
wow okay thank you good a big
breakthrough I'm in the same place I was
a month ago
and Lois is outside
um as a host checking customers coming
through
um arranging the table plan and almost
slightly looking concern which I like to
see a word that means she's moving
around I think it's going much better
it's much calmer the whole system is
working the first time we came to UTA he
was
sushi rice
I want to see if the big bad Geordie has
regained his passion for food
so I've challenged him to cook me
something special with my sea bass
all right
well it's more successful than the last
day
huh
[Music]
come on then what no just the face let
me ask you a question first yeah
um what do you think of the sea bass
I thought it was following along the
firms were
straightforwards not complicating the
flavors I think if I was to hop that
fish on the menu uh I think if we'll
probably fly out the door
I thought that this was um absolutely
fantastic yeah I haven't enjoyed it
excellent I mean that's the best dish
I've eaten at the sand Gate Hotel since
I've been here
next time I'll see you yeah you have a
baby girl or a baby boy you know what it
is come on
that oyster eating contest yes
that sea basketball's memorable what
more could you ask right
and don't tell him
I didn't really catch it I bought it
from the [__] fish mug
I really think this can work you know
that they've got all the ingredients and
I think they can really put this place
back on the map and be a great Seaside
Restaurant it needs a lot of hard work
and understanding that your customers
are [__] important nothing more than
that
[Music]
oh